[Music]
All right. Well, let's get started. Uh,
we don't have much time, but um, I hope
your conference is going well. Uh,
welcome to AI engineering worldfare. Uh,
my name is Dat No. Uh, today's talk is
about LME val pipelines. Um, so I never
know what I want to talk about till I
get into the room, so I don't prep too
hard. But by show of hands, who here uh
who here has built u an agent? Just
raise your hand. Okay. Uh, who here um
has run an eval?
Right. Who here has productionized an AI
product?
Nice. Okay. Some technical builders. Um,
let's get technical then. So, uh, my
name is, uh, Dat. Um, I'm an AI
architect at Arise AI. Um, this is Mochi
and Latte. Uh, Latte. They're uh dogs of
my friends. I figured let's let's keep
it spicy and interesting. Um, but I've
been building observability and eval
since since day zero. So, uh, since the
first uh I don't know if you guys know
what Arise AI is, but we are the largest
uh AI evals player uh in the space. So,
observability eval kind of beyond. Uh,
we work really heavily uh with with real
use cases. So, folks like Reddit, folks
like Dualingo. Um, so we work across the
best AI teams and we have a really
unique business. Being on the
observability side, we get to see what
everyone is building,
how they're tackling those problems,
what are their biggest pains, uh, and
what are the kind of the tips and tricks
that they use to to really productionize
these things. And just to give you a
hint, um, you know, Dualingo has massive
eval scale. They tend to run about 20
evals per per like um, trace. Um, so
they end up spending, you know, quite a
fair amount, uh, doing evals,
understanding their evals, optimizing
them. Uh, and the last thing about me, I
have a huge passion for the AI
community. Um, when I was in SF the last
5 years, uh, really loved to go to
pretty much every single event that I
could. I'm not a developer advocate. I'm
an engineering an engineer by by trade,
but I just love the community. So, um,
yeah, this is a little bit about Rise,
but I think I don't want to keep it too
salesy. I just want to keep it pretty
technical. So really three concepts that
I think everybody should be familiar
with and where eval really sit in the
space is is really as simple as this. Um
this is what I teach all my customers
really. The first thing is
observability. I think you guys have
kind of seen this before. Observability
really just answers the question of what
is the thing that I built actually
doing? Right? To some people it may be
traces uh traces in in spans. Um I'll
show you a little bit um you know
platform agnostic just just think about
the concepts. Um but traces might be one
one area for people. So traces represent
hey what's happening? Can I look at
things uh to an AI engineer makes a lot
of sense. Um let's say you're an AIPM
maybe not super technical or maybe uh
you want to think about things
differently. Maybe you want to look at
hey what are the conversations that are
happening. Turns out you can run evals
at these levels. Uh we'll get into that
in depth kind of later. Um you know
signal comes and observability comes in
different kind of flavors and forms.
Maybe it's it's analytics. Uh what we're
starting to really realize is that LLM
teams are getting split into two special
niches. There's platform teams, right?
And they they own things like the the
infrastructure. So who here has heard of
a model gateway router? It's like an
interface pattern behind it or all the
models, right? Well, turns out the
central LLM platform team tends to own
that. They care about cost, latency,
things like that. And then you have the
other LLM teams. these these LM teams s
team uh sit on the like the outer side
of the business so like a hub and spoke
they work for the business side so these
are like uh the people building the
applications to help the business so um
if anyone here comes from like the the
ML or or data science space it's
actually not far from that um and so
different teams care about different
metrics uh so maybe if you're an AIPM
sitting on the business side you care
about evals if you care about you know
the platform maybe you care about costs
latency things like that but TLDDR
uh observability oops uh observability
um represents what's happening and now
evals are really important in this space
because the reality of the fact is if
you've ever seen a trace or something
like that um you're not going to inspect
every single trace manually right it is
not scalable for you an AI engineer or
you the AIPM to look through these
things so what is eval used for it's
actually just a really clever word for
signal you're just trying to understand
what's going well and what's not going
well. So, I'm not here to sell you on
like evals. I think everybody knows how
important they are. But if you think
eval or LM as a judge only, uh there's
actually a lot of other tools that
you're missing. So, LM as a judge, raise
your hand if you used LM as a judge.
Okay, about half the room. Um it's super
great. Uh you use an LLM to give you
feedback or process on on any process,
including an LLM process. So, if you're
doing rag, this is a really good way to
to think about rag in terms of evals. um
rag would be like hey user has a
question um we retrieve some context to
be able to you know possibly answer that
question and then we generate an answer
turns out every arrow on this is
actually an eval you can run so hey I
retrieve some context and I want to
compare that to the query being asked
well that's rag relevance it's like is
the thing that I returned even helpful
in answering the question and so LM as a
judge is great it's super helpful um you
know I think most people understand why
it works But there's a whole there's a
whole research area on why they're
really good indicators. Um the original
task is not the eval task, right? So if
I asked you a human, hey, generate me a
summary on uh something long and complex
like the book War in Peace. Uh that's a
very different task than say, hey, I
wrote this summary for you. Is it a good
one or is it a bad one? But LM as a
judge is is a small part. Um it doesn't
always have to be a large language model
or auto reggressive model. Um things
like encoder only BERT type
architectures are super helpful. They're
about 10 times cheaper um about one or
two orders of magnitudes faster uh to
run that eval. But you know you don't
just have LLM at your disposal. You a
human also are really good way to
discern signal. So it turns out eval can
also come in the form of is your user
having a good or bad experience. So for
those people who've productionized uh
some sort of LLM application, do you
guys have user feedback? Raise your hand
if you've implemented user feedback and
okay about 30%. Uh it's actually
incredible signal. Um so that comes from
a human. Obviously you yourself can also
generate labels on stuff. So has anyone
here heard of a golden data set? Raise
your hand. Okay, most of the room. Um
and the way I encourage folks to think
about this, this is a pro tip actually.
If the first column represents scale, so
LM as a judge is valuable because I
don't have to grade it myself, right?
But let's say I don't necessarily trust
it off the bat. Use the third column to
help you out. So a golden data set
represents quality. So you yourself
graded it. You know that it's it's what
you expected, you know. Um well, turns
out you can run your LM as a judge on a
golden data set. Um what you're trying
to do is say, hey, can the LLM
approximate the thing that I trust?
Right? And what that allows you to do is
to actually quantify and tune your LM as
a judge. So we'll go over that in a
second, but strong pro tip. uh most
really strong LLM teams in the world
kind of do this today. Uh and it turns
out you don't always have to use an LLM
uh or a human. You can use what are
called like curistics or codebased
logic. So I'm going to take you into the
platform a little bit to talk through
it. But um in our platform you have a
way to to run evals. Great. Uh what code
evals actually are um are just um it's
much cheaper. So I'll just run a little
test here. But you know let's say you
want to say hey does this output contain
any keywords? I don't need to use an LLM
or human for that. I can just use code.
It's infinitely cheaper. Um faster to
run. Um does this match this reg x
pattern xyz? Is this a parsible JSON? So
the reality of it is you have this kind
of uh large toolbox in your kind of uh
eval set. So when you say evals, don't
just think of LLM as a judge. There's a
whole other set of smarter things that
you can use. They're actually more cost-
effective. And so really, you know, this
is a really good way to to emphasize
really the value of like the AI engineer
evals and observability. Most people
understand this this lefth hand circle,
this purple one. Um it actually
represents what we all want to do and
it's like hey build a better AI system,
right? So what you do is you collect
data observability traces things like
that. Then you run some evals to say hey
did this process go well or did this
process not go well? So you're
discerning signal from that, you know,
mass of data. You'll actually collect
where areas of things went right or
wrong, right? And you'll say, "Hey,
turns out we hallucinated on this. It's
because our rag strategy is off or the
agent is is off, for example." Um,
you'll also annotate data sets as well
just to double check that those eval are
correct. And then of course, you always
come back in into your platform and you,
you know, you update the the prompt
template, right? you change the model
because it's it's it wasn't good enough
or you update the agent orchestration.
So, everybody understands that lefth
hand circle. Now, a lot of people
actually forget about the right hand
circle. And so, it turns out the first
time you run evals, what you'll quickly
realize is that um they're not perfect,
right? You actually have to tune those
evals over time. So, the way you collect
signal actually adjusts as your
application also, you know, gets better.
And so what I mean by that is that
process of running evals, what you might
notice if you annotate some of them is
that the eval said something
hallucinated or wasn't correct and it
actually was or vice versa. Um so what
you actually need to do is collect a set
of those failures, right? Say, hey, this
is where the eval was wrong and you'll
know that by annotating some data every
now and again. Um and then you'll want
to improve the eval prompt template,
right? because the way you collect
signal at first um you'll quickly
realize it's either too obscure, too
vague, uh not specific enough. So these
are the kind of two virtuous cycles that
you really want to get through very
quickly. And the way I describe it to AI
engineering teams is if you want to
build an like a quality AI product, uh
think about velocity. So the faster you
iterate through stuff, if you I can get
through four iterations in a month
rather than two, you're going to
exponentially have a better AI product
as you build. And so when we talk about
architectures and things like that, um
when the industry first started, this
was state-of-the-art. Um routers, right?
Um am I right? Um so routers are made up
of like components. Um this is a really
dumb example of booking.com's trip
planner. Um so booking, you know,
they're one of our largest customers.
Trip planner is basically a travel agent
in LLM form. It drives revenue for that
company. It helps you book, you know,
it'll book your flights, your hotels.
It'll give you an itinerary. And so um
you know when we think about evals evals
can be as complex as the application
application itself. So in kind of older
architectures
um where there's things like routing um
you can you can evout individual
components. I think most people get this
when you're looking inside of a trace
for example um maybe I want to evout a
specific uh component or trace. So this
one LLM call, right? But remember, oops,
I'll come up here. But remember that you
can um Okay, remember that you can zoom
out too. So it doesn't have to just be
this one specific component. Let's say
this one component is part of an agent
or a workflow. Uh maybe I just want to
evaluate the input output of that larger
workflow. So that larger workflow is
made up of LLM calls, API calls, right?
I have to find actual flights, actual
hotels that have vacancy. Um maybe some
huristics.
And then you can zoom out a little bit
more. Uh maybe you want to eval things
like the way control flow happens. It's
a really important component. If you
have components in your AI agents that
have control flow in them, uh it
actually makes way more sense to eval
your control flow first and you have
conditional evals. Meaning if you didn't
get the control flow right, why eval
anything down the line? Because it's
probably wrong, right? So save solve
yourself some some money and some um
some costs. So you can think about
conditional evals as well. And then of
course we have things like um people
want to run evals at at the highest
level. So imagine you have a back and
forth. So we call this a session in in
our platform. But uh the whole idea is
you know a session is made up of a
series of traces. So you can imagine
there's a back and forth between your
you and your agent. I just want to
understand, hey, at any point was the
customer frustrated, was the customer
XYZ. So when you start to think about
evals, there's no one-stop shop. If
anybody like says this is how you should
do evals and they never asked you about
how your application works, you probably
shouldn't trust them. Also, I have a hot
take and my hot take is that don't use
out of the box evals. If you get out of
the box, if you use out of the box
evals, you'll get out of the box
results. Um, so really customize them
very heavily. It's something that we've
learned really from some of the best
teams in the world. Um, okay, let me
come here. Um, then you have complexity.
Um, this is our own architecture for uh
our AI co-pilot. Uh, we built an AI
whose one purpose is to troubleshoot,
observe, build evals for your AI system.
It obviously takes advantage of our
platform. But, you know, the reason why
we go this route is take us forward 5 10
years from now. Do you guys really think
that you, a human, are going to be the
ones who are evaluating all these AI
systems like manually? Um, what do you
think would actually take your place?
Um, it's probably going to be an AI that
evaluates future AI. So, this is our
first iteration on this stuff. Um, we're
super excited about it. Um, we, you
know, it's been out for a year. It's
getting better and better. But maybe
I'll show you a little bit of the
workflows that we have in in our
platform really quickly. Um, who here is
is working with agents? Okay. Who here
is interested in like agent evaluation?
Okay, let's cover that then. Let's see.
I'll show you we'll show you how the
industry is doing agent evals. So, with
agent evals, things get like way more
complex, right? The calls are longer,
which you look at your traces, they're
much longer. Um, I'll actually show you
uh our agent um traces. So, this is one
that kind of failed, but our agent trace
kind of works like this. So, Copilot
works like this. it basically based off
what you say and where you're at in the
platform, there's there's agents that
kind of can do things. So, um and it has
tools. Each agent has access to a set of
tools that it's particularly good at. Um
so, the whole idea is that yes, we can
see what each individual um trace is
doing, right? We can say, hey, what's
happening in this particular area? we
can look at the traces but the reality
of of what people are actually asking in
the space is not is my a AI agent good
or bad what they're actually asking is
what are the failure modes in which my
agent fails right and so what I mean by
that is you can look at one individual
uh trace and the graph view of it but
the reality is you want to understand
and discern the signal with your
entirety of your AI agent so what is the
like what does the pathing look like
across Ross all of that particular AI
agents um calls. So for instance, if it
had access to to 10 tools, maybe you
want to answer questions like how often
did it call a specific tool, right? Um
what were the evals in a specific path?
So in our agent graph for example, um
it's framework agnostic. So whether you
use langraph, whether you use crew AI,
whether you use your handrolled code, um
this is an agnostic way to look at um
you know how how an agent's pathing
performs across the aggregate traces. Um
and so this helps you understand okay if
my agent hits component one then two
then three uh my evals look great but
for some reason when we hit component
four then two then three our evals are
dropping. And the reason is why? Well,
oh, turns out component 4 had a
dependency right on component 3 and it
needs that dependency in order to
perform. And so when you think about the
complexity of agent evals, um you need
kind of the ability to see across not
one instantiation but all of them. You
need to understand the distribution of
what's happening. And so we think about
eval across agents. Um that's one way
you can think about it. And then maybe
an easier way to kind of think about it
too is um you know trajectory uh we're
thinking about trajectory eval. So
imagine for a second um you have this
specific input right and the input is
like you know hey find me these hotels
at trip planner and you know you should
hit this component then that component
this other component. So in this case
it's like start agent tool agent. You
might have a golden data set like very
similar to how we have golden data sets
for LM as a judge but this is for
trajectories. So I expect us to be able
to hit at least three or four of these
components for example. So the reference
trajectory is kind of mentioned like I
need to hit these components. Then you
can do do two two things one of two
things. Either one you can pass in like
here's what we did here's what we
expected into an LLM and then an LLM can
actually grade the trajectory. Um you
can also just say hey did we explicitly
hit these exact like trajectory strings?
Great. Um but you don't always need a
ground truth for that. You can start to
get creative here. you can say, hey, you
know, here's this process that I
expected to hit. Do the does these nodes
and the description of their nodes match
the correct correct trajectory, for
instance. Um, and then maybe you could
do things like we're kind of playing
around with this, but maybe here's the
trajectory that I hit. Uh, here's the
possible paths that are just possible.
Did I do well in these specific areas,
right? And you can pass in the pathing
as a series of like nested key value
pairs, for example. LM are pretty good
at that. But we start to think about um
you know Asian evals. You know the eval
space is already complex enough and what
we're seeing is even more complexity. Um
but hopefully that makes sense. Um I'll
pause here. Um hopefully that makes
sense. But usually I like to make time
for questions at the end and keep this
pretty interactive. Um hope that's okay
team. But any questions? Does this make
sense?
Cool. No questions. Oh yeah. Go ahead.
mostly.
Yeah, incredible question. So, a lot of
people So, there's evals that can be um
you know some people call them offline
or online. Um I like to say is like is
it in the path is it in orchestration or
out of orchestration. So for some people
there's a cost to in in orchestration
evals and the cost is things like
latency right some people might call
those a guardrail too like hey can I
continue or not continue um and so
there's pros and cons to everything I
think when it comes to guardrails this
is something I I kind of coach my
customers the way to think about
guardrails um in general is you have
system one system one is your
orchestration system it's what you built
it's your prompts it's everything else
system two is your guardrail system
Right? Guards are really nice because
they they mitigate risk, right? But
there is a cost and the cost is maybe
it's latency in your users's experience.
You can get around that by doing smart
things like maybe embedding guardrails.
They're, you know, two orders of
magnitude shorter. Um, but a lot of
people don't think about the other two
cons here. The other con is complexity.
Two systems is complex, especially when
one system checks in with the first. The
third thing is that a lot of people
mistake guardrails as like the thing
that needs to be adjusted. A lot of
people will go to their guardrails first
like, "Oh, I need to adjust my
guardrails." Reality is you need to
adjust system one. That's the root
cause, right? Your guardrails are really
there to protect you. And then maybe the
last thing I'll say too is guardrails
are not infallible. They're they kind of
act like unit tests. They're for known
knowns, right? whereas observability
plus eval
because the reality is you don't know
the distribution of what you're going to
see until you get there right um ask
anybody who's built in the LM space uh
their users are just crazy and so um
that that's the difference and I and I
really caution people because people are
like oh I need to fix my guardrail no go
fix the prompt first and then worry
about your guardrails but yeah inline we
call those inline uh eval guardrails but
really do you do the eval in the
orchestration or outside of it. Um, and
so you can there's pros and cons. So
there's no right or wrong answer there,
but good question.
Yeah. So when we have a complex system
that is taking a long time to run and we
have timeouts in this and I know we all
have something called span that limits
what
kind of view we're taking to a complex
agent. So we have like a complex system
that's really going to take time and
then there's an asynchronous Is there
support to manage something like that
and eval across the whole system that we
have? Oh yeah, amazing question. So um
who here has ever heard of OTEL? Open
telemetry. Okay, even less than Okay. Um
one of the most important things to our
enterprise customers is is being on open
telemetry. Um so you know how I said LM
teams are being split into two. Well,
turns out LM services are also being
split across services. And so the idea
is like people want to understand um so
maybe an asynchronous process in one
service or one docker contain or you
know one one docker or one kubernetes
pod. Um oel propagation is a great way
to get around that. Meaning you can have
a process like application A sends data
to my model router right and then that
comes back to application A. Then
application A hits application B for
some reason and then it comes back to A.
when you're actually creating those
traces, you want to be able to see all
that work, right? You don't want to just
instrument one particular thing. You
want to see it across work across. And
so is an incredible pattern for that.
It's a solved problem. So that's why we
at Arise two and a half years ago when
this crazy time started for all of us,
we made a bet to be hotel first and it's
it's really paid off. Um yeah. Yeah.
So just ask your experience.
Okay. So confidence scores on evals,
right? Um yeah, I think it depends where
you're getting your eval. If it's from
an auto reggressive model, um companies
like OpenAI have actually exposed the
log prop. So the log probability is it's
pseudo like confidence of like and since
you're returning only one coat token and
that token is like the the eval label
log prop is a really good way for those
auto reggressive models if you're using
things like um small language models
encoder only models they come with a
probability uh of the classification. Um
but really yeah it's tough but you have
a bunch of tools in your toolbox and you
generally use them together to discern
where things go well or not well. log
prop if you're using uh a model provider
that exposes the log prop is is a really
good way to start for auto reggressive
models.
Okay, last question and then we're time
up. Yeah. Are you making your plans like
going forward like how to shorten the
loop between customer feedback?
Oh, good question. Yeah, we want to
automate in that area definitely. So,
who here has heard of DSPY?
All right. And okay, if you if you
didn't raise your hand on any of this, I
hope you learned a bunch. Um, DSPY
obviously has something like MIRO. Uh,
Miro is an optimizer. You get like 30
inputs, 30 outputs, and then um it
basically creates less fragile prompts
that span across different models like
so it does it works for OpenAI and then
it works for Gemini, etc. Uh, in terms
of like auto optimization, yeah, I think
we have the ability to or we're
releasing the ability to run uh prompt
optim optimization. So some people call
it we call it metapar prompting but
basically we feed it a data set we said
here's the input output pairs here's the
eval on those things uh and where things
failed and didn't fail look at the
original prompt look at this data set
can you give me a new prompt that fixes
this data set yeah so we we have we call
that meta prompting but it's basically
use an LLM to just automate so you don't
have to yeah but good question but
really appreciate the time uh we're over
at the booth uh feel free to come grab
me if you want to talk architecture or
or anything. But really nice to see you
all.
[Music]